it's 1996 in Avira and eastern Congo
this is McKenney militia commanders walk
into his village knock on his neighbor's
doors and whisk their children away to
training camps boo kenny borrows a video
camera from a local wedding photographer
he disguises as a journalist and he
walks into the camps to negotiate the
release of the children he films footage
of the children being trained as
soldiers many of these children are
under 15 years old and that is a war
crime but you don't have to go to
eastern Congo to find human rights
abuses in America a country with a
rapidly aging population experts
estimate that 1 in 10 people over 60
will experience abuse it's a hidden
epidemic and most of that abuse actually
happens at the hands of close caretakers
or family this is Vicky Vicky put an
iron gate on her bedroom door and she
became a prisoner in fact in her own
house out of fear for her nephew who had
taken over her home as a drug den and
this is Mary Mary picked up a video
camera for the first time in her life
when she was 65 years old and she asked
Vicky and 99 other older people who had
experienced abuse to tell their stories
on camera and I am Dutch so in the
Netherlands we are obsessed with the
truth now when you're a child that's a
great thing because you can basically
get away with anything like yes mama it
was me who smoked the cigars
but I think this is why I have dedicated
my life to promoting citizen video to
expose young rights violations because I
believe in the power of video to create
undeniable truth and my organization
witness helped use the Congolese videos
to help convict and send a notorious
warlord called Thomas Lubanga to jail
and the videos that Mary shot we trained
Mary and many other elder justice
advocates to make sure that the stories
of elder abuse reached lawmakers and
those stories helped convince lawmakers
to pass landmark legislation to protect
older Americans so I wonder billions of
us now have this powerful tool in our
right at our fingertips it's a camera so
why are all of us not a more powerful
army of civic witnesses like Mary and
Boo Kenny why is it that so much more
video is not leading to more rights and
more justice and I think it is because
being an eyewitness is hard your story
will get the night your video will get
lost in a sea of images your story will
not be trusted and you will be targeted
so how do we help witnesses in Oaxaca in
Mexico the teachers movement organized a
protest after the president pushed down
very undemocratic reforms the federal
police came down in buses and started
shooting at the protesters at least
seven people died and many many more
were wounded
images started circulating of the
shootings and the Mexican government did
what it always does it issued a formal
statement and the statement basically
accused the independent media of
creating fake news it said we were not
there that was not us doing the shooting
this did not happen but we had just
trained activists in Mexico to use
metadata strategically with their images
now metadata is the kind of information
your camera captures that shows the date
the location the temperature the weather
it can even show a very unique way you
hold your camera when you capture
something so the images started
recirculating and this time with the
very verifying validating information on
top of them
and the federal government had to
retract their statement now justice for
the people of Oaxaca is still far off
for their stories their truth can no
longer be denied so we started thinking
what if you had proof mom what if
everybody had a camera in their hands
and all the platforms had that kind of
validating ability so we developed
together with amazing guardian Android
developers called the Guardian project
we developed something called a
technology that's called proof mote that
marries those metadata together with
your image and it validates and it
verifies your video now imagine there's
there is a deluge of images coming from
the world camera phones imagine if that
information could be trusted just a
little bit more what the potential would
be for journalists for human rights
investigators for human rights lawyers
so we started sharing proof mode with
our partners in Brazil who are an
amazing media collective called Coletivo
papa hito Brazil is a tough place for
human rights the brazilian police kills
thousands of people every year the only
time that there's an investigation guess
when when there's a video 17 year old
Eduardo was killed in broad daylight by
the Rio police and look what happens
after they kill him they put a gun in
the dead boy's hand they shoot the gun
twice to fabricate their story of
self-defense the woman who filmed this
was a very very courageous eyewitness
and she had to go into hiding after she
posted her video for fear of her life
but people are filming and they're not
going to stop filming so we're now
working together with media collectives
so the resonance on their whatsapp
frequently get guidance and tips on how
to film safely how to upload the video
that you shoot safely how to capture a
scene so that it can actually count as
evidence and here's an inspiration from
a group of media ninja in Brazil the man
on the left is a heavily armed military
policeman he walks up to a protester
when you protest in Brazil you can be
arrested or worse and he says to the
protester watch me I am going to search
you right now and the protester is a
live streaming activist he wears a
little camera and he says to the
military policeman he says I am watching
you and there are 5,000 people watching
you with me now the tables are turned
the distant witnesses the watching
audience they matter so we started
thinking what if you could tap into that
power the power of distant witnesses
what if you could pull in their
expertise their leverage their
solidarity their skills when a frontline
community needs them to be there and we
started developing a project that's
called mobilize us because many of us I
would assume want to help and and lend
our skills and our expertise but we are
often not there in a frontline community
or a single individual faces and abuse
and it could be as simple as this little
app that we created that just shows the
perpetrator on the other side of the
phone
how many people are watching him but now
imagine that you could put a layer of
computer tasks routing on top of that
imagine that your community facing an
immigration rate and at that very moment
at that right moment for your live
stream you could pull in a hundred legal
observers how'd that change the
situation so we started piloting this
with our partner communities in Brazil
this is a woman called Camilla and she
was able she's the leader in a favela
called favela skull she was able to pull
in distant witnesses via livestream to
help translation to help distribution to
help amplify her story after her
community was forcibly evicted to make
room for a very glossy Olympic events
last summer so we're talking about good
witnessing but what happens if the
perpetrators are filming what happens if
it bystander films and doesn't do
anything this is the story of Chrissy
Chrissy is a transgender woman who
walked into a McDonald's in Maryland to
use the woman's bathroom two teens
viciously beat her for using that
woman's bathroom and the McDonald's
employee filmed this on his mobile phone
and he posted his video and it has
garnered thousands of racist and
transphobic comments so we started a
project that's called capturing hey we
took a very very small sample of
eyewitness videos that showed abuse
against transgender and gender
non-conforming people
we searched two words [ __ ] fight and
stud fight and those 329 videos were
watched and are still being watched as
we sit here in this theater a stunning
almost 90 million times and there are
hundreds of thousands of comments with
these videos adding on to more violence
and more Hey so we started developing a
methodology that took all that
unquantified for visual evidence and
turned it into data turning video into
data and with that tool LGBT
organizations are now using that data to
fight for rights and we take that data
and we take it back to Silicon Valley
and we say to them how is it possible
that this this
these videos are still out there in a
climate of hate egging on more hate
summoning more violence when you have
policies that actually say you do not
allow these kinds of this kind of
content urging them to change their
policies so I have hope I have hope that
we can turn more video into more rights
and more justice 10 billion people video
views on snapchat per day so what if we
could turn that snapchat generation into
effective and safe civic witnesses what
if they could become the book Kenny's of
this new generation in India women have
already started using snapchat filters
to protect their identity when they
speak out about domestic violence the
truth is the real truth the truth it
doesn't fit into any TED talk is
fighting your rights abuse is hard there
are no easy solutions for human rights
abuse and there's not a single piece of
technology that can ever stop the
perpetrators but for the survivors for
the victims for the marginalized
communities their stories their truths
matter and that is where justice begins
thank you
[Applause]